les carnets de voyage c'est le souvenir
qui s'inscrit à travers les écrits les
photos au retour d'une rencontre avec un
pays avec la bibliothèque départementale
les carnets de voyage deviennent des
parcours initiatique où le voyage
commence dans la tête et se poursuivra
peut-être dans un avenir proche ou
lointain ce qui est sûr c'est que les
400 marmailles qui ont fabriqué leur
carnet de voyage en se tournant vers
l'orient savent désormais qu'une partie
de leur héritage provient de l' empire
du milieu
nous avons réuni 17 classes 17 classes
qui ont travaillé toute l'année sur un
voyage en chine à travers les livres et
c'est un moment où de restitution tous
ces élèves de la primaire au collège se
sont donc retrouvés pour la restitution
de leurs travaux du côté de l'espace
régler un moment familial qui a permis
aux tout petits de présenter différents
spectacles
bien
salah qui ferait un joli voyage dans un
grand pays at elle agi haché maintien ne
veut d'ailleurs sa mort en russie pour
des travaux que les enfants ont déjà
fait j'ai fait un tour tout à l'heure
dans la salle j'ai vu que j'ai pas mal
de choses concernant la chine pour le
conseil départemental permettre à tous
ces enfants de pouvoir découvrir la
chine c'est leur permettre d'aller à la
rencontre de leurs racines et de
s'ouvrir gestion que je suis très belle
initiative du conseil départemental fait
découvrir aux enfants d'où est née notre
peuple mans nos racines notre vivre
ensemble dans le métissage tous ceux qui
ont pu qui sont arrivées de part et
d'autre de tout horizon peuple et la
réunion et en même temps montrer à nos
enfants que aujourd'hui le vivre
ensemble et comportant une année
scolaire qui a vu plusieurs séquences se
dérouler du côté de la bibliothèque
départementale des travaux réalisés avec
l'aide des agents de la structure mais
également du collectif air du temps
résultat deux magnifiques carnet qui
font la fierté des enfants des parents
et des professeurs car les faits
et les aurais je fait un carnet est
dedans il ya comme des paysages et de
leurs fleurs et et sur ce carnet gmi
accord de dragon on a fait des dessins
comme ça et de raconter des histoires de
chine
tout ça c'est bien j'aime bien dedans
c'est que sa présence que l'afrique au
niveau des dessins c'est très beau nous
de toute façon la vie quand même pas du
tout vous connais pas du tout la chine
en fait et c'est à travers lui en fait
qu au voyage nous avons un partenariat
avec la bibliothèque cette année c'était
le thème de la chine nous avons aussi
travaillé à l'école des albums sur la
chine sur l'horoscope chinois
puis nous avons eu quelques séances sus
je crois dans l'année à la bibliothèque
départementale où là les enfants
entendent des histoires et ensuite
travail sur la fabrication d'un quart
nettoyage sur la chine après les îles de
l'océan indien l'afrique l'inde
nous voilà rendus en chine et voyage au
delà des mers dans l'autre sens que
celui parcouru par ces milliers d'
engager à l'origine du peuplement de la
rue
j